I mentioned software caching as a
mechanism that's available in exokernel for establishing
secure binding. And software TLB is one specific example of using the software
caching idea. As we know, when we have a context switch one of the biggest
sources of performance loss is the fact that you're losing locality
for the newly scheduled process. And since the
address base occupied by this library operating system
and this library operating system are necessarily completely
different, when we switch from one library operating system
to another, we have to flush out the entire TLB. And if we do that, when
we run this other library operating system, it's
not going to find any of its virtual addresses in
the TLB. And that's a huge source of overhead and in order to mitigate that
overhead, exokernel has this mechanism called software
TLB. The idea is quite simple, the software
TLB is sort of a snapshot of the hardware TLB for each of the operating
systems. So this software TLB, if a data
structure in the exokernel that represents the mappings
for operating system one. Similarly, this
data structure represents the mapping for library
operating system number two. So let's
say currently we're running library operating system
one. So the TLB entries correspond
to valid mappings for library operating systems
one. And let's say that exokernel decides
to switch from this library operating system
to this one. At that point, what exokernel
will do is dump the TLB into the software
TLB data structure it has on behalf of
OS1. Actually not all of the TLB, but we'll
get to that later on, some subset of
the TLB mappings will be dumped into this data
structure. And let's say that we are switching from
this library operating system to this library operating system.
In that case, what exokernel is going to do is, it's going to pre-load the
TLB with the software TLB data set that
is associated with this library operating system. Essentially,
what we are accomplishing is that when the
library operating system starts running on the CPU
it will find some of its mappings already
present in the hardware TLB. That's the idea
in exokernel of having the STLB data structure
associated with every library operating system to mitigate
the loss of locality that happens when you
do context switch, in terms of address translations.
Of course, when the library operating system starts
running, and it does not find a mapping
for a virtual address in the TLB, at
that point, exokernel is going to kick up that
missing virtual page translation in the TLB as a page fault up into the
library operating system and you'll get result exactly as we detailed earlier.